naufrage d'un chalutier français au
large de l'ecosse 18 pêcheurs
originaires de fécamp sont morts ou
portés disparus deux palestiniens un
meurtrier d'un représentant de l olp
libéré sous conditions expulsés de
france après sept années de prison peut
être un lien avec la négociation pour
libérer les quatre otages français du
liban 16e lancement de la fusée ariane
cette nuit depuis le centre spatial de
kourou en guyane il faut à tout prix
éviter l'échec
les césar du cinéma français décernés
demain et en direct sur antenne 2 en
poche a choisi ses ronds bonsoir dans
l'atlantique au large de l'ecosse en
pleine nuit un chalutier usine de dieppe
le snekkar arctic a fait naufrage il y
avait 27 hommes à bord dix huit d'entre
eux sont morts ou portés disparus
seuls deux corps ont jusqu'à présent pu
être retrouvés et l'on pense
tragiquement à cette phrase d'une
chanson c'est pas l'homme qui prend la
mer c'est la mer qui prend l'homme
une importante opération de recherches
maritimes et aériennes a été organisée
toute cette journée
mais le temps est très mauvais on ignore
encore très précisément les raisons de
ce naufrage par c'est rien nous sommes
ici à bord du snekkar arctic l'un des
bateaux de pêche industrielle les plus
modernes de france film et il y a
quelques semaines la plupart de ces
hommes étaient à bord cette nuit vers 3h
28 lorsque chalutier pêchant à proximité
a lancé un sos
le snekkar arctic vient de couler le
radio du bateau naufragé avait tout
juste eu le temps de l'ancien de message
de détresse
beaucoup dorment et le snekkar arctic
était partie de dieppe le 12 février
pour une campagne de quatre semaines à
l'ouest des côtes écossaises
au moment du naufrage le chalutier
pêcher à environ 700 km des côtes
c'est depuis le centre de secours en mer
du port écossais de greenock que sans
diriger les secours sur le tableau on
fait les comptes
heure par heure encore 18 marins
français manquant ils étaient 26 hommes
d'équipage 9 ont été recueillis au petit
jour il avait trouvé refuge dans un
canot de sauvetage du type bombe à 17
sont portées disparues un marin un autre
chalutier a été emportés par une lame
sous les ordres de ses hommes dix sept
chalutiers des avions et des
hélicoptères participent aux recherches
mais l'espoir s'amenuise trois corps ont
été retrouvés à fécamp et dans quelques
autres ports français en attend avec
angoisse et nouvelle venue des causses
nous venons de joindre par téléphone
madame jouant l épouse du capitaine du
snekkar arctic chez davigel en moteurs
du sénégal arctique on ne comprend pas
ce qui a pu arriver à ce bateau ultra
moderne qui était la fierté de diabaté
aussi vous voulez sont normalement sont
normalement construit de toute façon je
suis comme tous les gros chalutiers pour
aborder
le temps qu'on rencontre normalement
revenir d'une heure c'est à dire que
normalement ils sont aptes à affronter
les grosses mains oui normalement si
vous voulez sont tout à fait exquis sont
énormément tout à perdre
au moment du naufrage la mer était assez
peu agité le snec art arctique a
peut-être été victime de son
extraordinaire mécanisation
parmi les hypothèses plausibles une
panne générale d'électricité au moment
de la remontée du chalut rempli par dix
tonnes de poissons tout se bloque et le
navire est brusquement déséquilibré
autre hypothèse une vague déferlante qui
remplit le bateau au moment où les cales
sont ouvertes sur les bateaux de pêche
aujourd'hui le modernisme a tout changé
sauf une chose le danger permanent
imprévisible la france a décidé
d'expulser deux palestiniens condamnés
pour le meurtre d'un représentant de
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine monsieur ezzeddine callac
meurtres commis en 1978 à paris
les deux hommes avaient été condamnés à
15 ans de réclusion criminelle ils ont
effectué la moitié de leur peine
juridiquement il était possible de les
expulser a brièvement commenté laurent
fabius
c'est donc une décision politique prise
au plus haut niveau qui a entraîné cette
expulsion des deux palestiniens plus de
sept ans après leur acte terroriste
commentaire de révo il fallait tuer à
n'importe quel prix 8 août 78 les locaux
de l'organisation de libération de la
palestine
devenu champ de bataille jet de grenade
fusillade de mort azzedine callac chef
du bureau noël paix et son adjoint les
assassins ils sont presque aussitôt
arrêté sur les lieux même de l'attentât
est sans opposer de grande résistance
asad sayeed et us ni hatem palestiniens
eux aussi mais membre du front du refus
l'organisation du dissident abou nidal
l'ennemi du chef de l'olp et yasser
arafat abou nidal le responsable de
nombreux attentats antisémites et de la
mort de plusieurs palestiniens modérés à
leur procès en mars 80 les deux jeunes
hommes déclarent qu'ils avaient une
mission qu'ils sont des soldats
il écope de quinze ans de réclusion
criminelle purger dans une prison de
muret
ici même très de toulouse le 5 février
dernier
ils quittent leur cellule libre une
levée d'écrou très discrète au petit
matin
leur avocat n'est même pas au courant
officiellement cette sortie de prison
n'est que l'application de la loi le
code de procédure pénale réserve dans
ses articles 729 et 730 la libération
conditionnelle pour tous condamnés
parvenu à la moitié de sa peine
c'est le cas pour les deux hommes mais
en fait la décision est politique prise
au plus haut niveau
elle respecte une promesse vieille de
trois ans ou 2,82 après la rue des
rosiers la rue marbeuf des attentats
imputés au groupe abou nidal l'état
français a négocié les termes de l
échange la libération à brève échéance
des de lieutenant d'abou nidal contre la
fin de cette vague de violence
quatre ans après le contrat est honoré
de part et d'autre semble-t-il
alors cette libération sous conditions
puis cette expulsion est dehors alors
fait inévitablement penser ce qui se
passe au liban c'est aux quatre otages
françaises qu'il ya un lien écoutez a
priori si on regarde tous les éléments
il n'y a aucun lien entre les deux
affaires
les deux palestiniens libérés par paris
est r on vient de le voir membres du
groupe terroriste abu nidal les otages
eux sont aux mains de terroristes du
hezbollah libanais contrôlé par un
mouvement iranien mais ça devient
intéressant quand on sait qu abu nidal a
ses entrées à damas damas qui a servi et
qui sert d'interlocuteur entre paris et
les ravisseurs des quatre otages
français
alors on peut se demander si paris en
libérant ses deux palestiniens d'abou
nidal ne cherche pas en fait à dire aux
autres vous voyez nous on respecte nos
contrats et si on se souvient que début
janvier l'accord conclu pour la
libération des otages a tourné court au
dernier moment parce que les ravisseurs
en demander plus on imagine très bien
que paris envoie ce message en se disant
aussi que l'essentiel et ce serait bien
avant les élections c'est la libération
des quatre français demain en effet cela
fera onze mois que marcel carton et
marcel fontaine sont retenus prisonniers
à beyrouth où quelque part au territoire
libanais cela fera aussi très exactement
demain 9 mois que michel seurat et jean
paul kauffmann sont les otage
d'extrémistes difficilement contrôlable
pour annoncer plusieurs manifestations
dont celle de rennes demain
madame kaufmann tenait aujourd'hui une
nouvelle conférence de presse à paris
elle est l'un des symboles de la
solitude de ces femmes de tout âge qui
se battent pour obtenir la libération de
leurs maris
tellement les amis et la famille tout ce
qu'on peut faire c'est parler
essayer de rencontrer le plus grand gens
possible
prendre on a rencontré beaucoup de gens
politique on en comptait beaucoup de
représentants des pays autour et pour
nous l'espoir c'était ça des petits
c'est un réseau d'amitiés qui fera qu'au
bout d'un moment tout le monde voudrait
doute été c'est peut-être un petit peu
ce qui est en train de se faire mousser
l'accessibilité
et puis c'est aussi ici ça peut prendre
pouvoirs publics n'est plus possible
tout le monde souffre trop là dedans
pour le parc on nous rendre des gens
complètement cassé au maximum maintenant
pour saab une déclaration de l'ex
président à vie d'haïti jean claude
duvalier le seul pays que j'ai choisie
et la france je vais me battre pour
obtenir le statut auquel j'ai droit avec
ma famille en pologne trois des
principaux dirigeants de l'opposition
membres de solidarité
messieurs fera signe ou de buck danny
c'est adam michnik resteront en prison
la cour suprême de pologne a réduit
certes les peines des deux derniers mais
elles y feront eux-mêmes au moins deux
ans de prison en italie une jeune femme
soupçonnée d'appartenir à l'union
communistes combattantes un groupe
proche des brigades rouges a été tué ce
matin lors d'un attentat contre un
fonctionnaire la président du conseil
italien
cet homme a été blessé mais le chauffeur
sa voiture à riposter contre le groupe
terroriste ont sur le coup donc cette
jeune femme peu avant 3h du matin heure
française cette nuit la dernière des
fusées ariane 1 doit être lancé depuis
le centre spatial de kourou en guyane
c'est un test important pour la fusée
européenne qui doit retrouver toute sa
fiabilité
après l'échec du 13 septembre dernier et
ce en présence du président mitterrand
d'autant qu ariane transportera un
satellite français d'auto détection très
important voyez les explications de
patrick esther à coup vous de fusées
ariane attendre leur lancement la
première sera tirée cette nuit à 2h44
mais après l'échec du mois de septembre
les techniciens ne prendrons aucun
risque quitte à retarder le tir cette
nuit ariane ne peut pas rater c'est la
crédibilité même du programme qui est en
jeu un tir d'autant plus important que
l'un des deux satellites qui se trouve à
bord représente un sommet de la
technologie spatiale européenne
un engin d'un milliard et demi de francs
le satellite d'observation de la terre
spot
un monstre fabriqués à toulouse par
matra près de deux tonnes 4 mètre
soixante dix de haut
équipé de deux télescopes électronique
il enregistrera à 830 km d'altitude les
paysage défilant sous lui sur 60 km de
large
des images renvoyées par radio vers les
antennes du centre de toulouse qui
permettront de distinguer les détails de
10 mètres sur 10 ici par exemple la
place de l'étoile et le bois de boulogne
ces vues seront commercialisés par la
société spot image 37 pays ont déjà
signé des accords financiers
une scène scott se présentera soit sous
forme de bandes magnétiques soit sous
forme d'image photographique dans les
deux cas la scène représente 60 km par
60 km et son prix sera de l'ordre de 9
mille ans sur bande magnétique est de
l'ordre de 2000 à 3000 francs sous forme
de films photographiques les
utilisations de ces vues seront
multiples surveillance de la pollution
des rivages évolution des estuaires le
satellite distinguera même les
différentes variétés d'algues
surveillance des cultures il deviendra
possible de prévoir des mois al avance
le niveau des récoltes ou les attaques
des parasites en cartographie l'outil
sera précieux quelques heures suffiront
pour corriger le plan d'une ville en
quelques jours le satellite permettra de
tracer la carte de pays n'ayant jamais
été décidée dans les atlas
c'est depuis l'espace que notre terre
livre le plus facilement ses secrets
nouvelle rubrique dans ce journal des
élections 86 celle des sondages il ya
beaucoup de sondages cette fin de
semaine ils donnent tous une même temps
je crois pour la wii ce sera désormais
la rubrique du vendredi elle nous
permettra de faire le point sur l'état
de l'opinion publique
si l'élection avait lieu aujourd'hui
quel serait le vote des français
la réponse de michel brûlé directeur de
l'institut bbva
karim fois consécutive depuis le mois de
décembre un sondage national des verts
paris match fait apparaître un
resserrement de l'écart des intentions
de vote entre la gauche et la droite qui
n'est plus aujourd'hui que de 10 points
avec 44% des intentions de vote à la
gauche et 54% à la droite
sur le plan des sièges cependant on
constate que la droite parlementaire
c'est-à-dire le rpr et l'udf
s'assurerait toujours une majorité
relativement confortable dans la
prochaine assemblée avec 316 députés ce
paradoxe apparent s'explique par le fait
que si le total les intentions de vote
pour la droite a diminué les intentions
de vote en faveur du rpr et de l'udf
elles pendant le même temps ont augmenté
en ce qui concerne la popularité du
président de la république on observe
qu'il poursuit sa remontée avec un gain
de 5 points entre le mois de janvier et
le mois de février qu'il met aujourd'hui
avec 44% d'opinions favorables contre
47% d'opinions critique
vous aviez raison tous les sondages
coïncide à un ou deux points près tous
les instituts indique le même rapport de
force progression du parti socialiste
mais majorité absolue en sièges pour le
rpr et l'udf
quant au parti communiste l'hémorragie
s'arrêterait il gagne même un petit
point mais c'est insuffisant pour
espérer un retour des beaux jours les
électeurs communistes sont encore
troubles et serge ministre et yvon
bardes l'ont constaté en suivant un
ancien ministre communiste qui semble
regretter le temps de l'union marcel
rigou salut
8h du matin la journée commence par une
brève réunion de travail
marcel guigou c'est plutôt un bosseur
dit on de lui dans la région à un âge où
part normalement à la retraite il s'en
va battre la campagne pour récupérer son
siège de député je voulais raccrocher
les gants explique-t-il mais de tout
parent m'a pressé de remonter sur le
ring
surtout il ne faut pas que l'on croit
que le parti m'a écarté après les revers
électoraux du pc marcel rigou a été
parmi ceux qui sont apparus comme des
comices de critiques
vous dites que je veux faire vivre la
différence dire quoi il la différence et
si tout simplement prendre en compte la
réalité
toute personne est différente chaque
personne n'a fait dans le moule et je
crois que la diversité c'est la richesse
torgon la division c'est l'impuissance
la différence elle apparaît ici sur le
terrain pour une fois les militants
parlent sans complexe devant la caméra
qui est pourquoi vous êtes partie civile
gouvernement et qui maintenant ma me
fait peur maintenant pour voter il faut
avoir conscience communique aux
socialistes la balle à droite chez une
femme vraiment faim entre socialistes et
communistes maintenant d'un résident
rien finalement
nous vous pensez que nous aurions dû
rester au gouvernement il y en a
beaucoup qui pense que nous aurions dû
partir plus tôt
ce sont précisément les gens qui
hésitent qu'il faut ramener au bercail
et ce sont ceux là que le parti
communiste jeu convaincre à tout prix
marcel rigou en bon militant six emplois
de son mieux même si parfois cela ne
fait pas tout le monde dans cette
campagne électorale la télévision c'est
une évidence joue un rôle important les
hommes politiques bien sûr sacrifier aux
traditions en courant de meeting en
meeting mais ils savent qu'un passage à
la télé même très bref peut-être plus
efficace encore faut-il réussir certains
sont doués d'autres un peu moins alors
ils apprennent en toute humilité
ils apprennent à convaincre la caméra
indiscrète d'olivier lerner et de
christian iru a surpris deux d'entre eux
au maximum le problème pour vous c'est
de faire passer un message humain sur le
problème de l'emploi en expliquant quand
même ce plan technique
comment vous entendez arriver à ce
challenge est extraordinaire c'est de
dire on va créer plus d'emplois en
france
alors est-ce que vous pouvez en deux
minutes essayé de faire passer ce
message
quand vous démarrez une interview avec
un journaliste
la première réponse faite là en 5 10
secondes vous donner un rythme à
l'interview vous donner l'impression aux
journalistes que vous voulez répondre à
ces questions et vous lui donnez
sentiment qui c'est lui qui a la
maîtrise de l'entretien par conséquent
il ya des solutions
ce sont des solutions qui ont fait leurs
preuves il faut les mettre en oeuvre
combien de temps passez les ennemis j'ai
dépassé les deux minutes que vous
l'aviez un parti ça dure et 3 mieux j'ai
bon non pas du tout faits une minute et
45 secondes
alors je suis resté à la limite sans que
de juin dix ans trop content et santé
publique sans rentrer au camp nou et si
tu es un mot vous avez prévu avance donc
je pensais entre une trentaine ont été
meilleurs dans la deuxième que ça va
sûrement
actuellement il ya en france trois
millions de chômeurs un jeune sur quatre
est obligé de s'inscrire au chômage
c'est un problème très grave qui
concerne toutes les familles françaises
elle a des chances de se démarquer ne
serait ce que par sa situation
géographique qui est au carrefour de
l'europe du nord tout près de la suisse
alémanique bâle zurich et tout près de
l'allemagne rhénane je crois que c'est
une très très bonne
un très bel atout qu'est ce que vous
apporte un conseiller en marketing
politique et il ya une chose à laquelle
je tiens beaucoup
c'est de ne pas être sous l'affluence de
quelqu'un vous avez tout le corps du
héros
vous n'avez pas complètement une
technique utilisée avant c'est de faire
un peu de gymnastique en vous sauriez sa
belle a pas beaucoup le thème facile
dans les déclarations aux médias il ya
celle de laurent fabius à l'express qui
dit laissez-moi à côté ce qu'on a semé
et puis laurent fabius qui accuse
monsieur chirac d'être une girouette à
propos de sa position sur la
privatisation des chaînes de télévision
monsieur toubon d'affirmer que rien
n'était changé pour le rpr en fait
jacques chirac n'a pas changé d'avis le
rpr s'il gagne à bien l'intention de
privatiser deux des chaînes publiques de
télévision mais il ne le fera pas tout
de suite pour des raisons techniques
mais aussi financière cette nuance
illustre tout de même le comportement
politique de jacques chirac qui
continuent de condamner sans détour le
gouvernement socialiste mais qui ne le
fait pas systématiquement on l'a vu à la
suite des attentats terroristes on l'a
vu à la suite de la nomination de robert
badinter au conseil constitutionnel
comme si le maire de paris voulait
préserver une chance même minime d'une
cohabitation avec le chef de l'état
c'est ce qu'il appelle la règle du jeu
les français économise même sur la grève
le nombre de journées de travail perdues
en 1985 pour cause de grève local ou
national est retombé au niveau de 1946
ce sont les statistiques publiées par le
ministère du travail il y a beaucoup de
raisons à cela dont celle sans doute de
la peur du chômage
voyez-les en quête de gérard leclerc que
sont les grèves d'antan devenu où sont
les grands mouvements sociaux 1936 le
front populaire et les balles dans les
usines occupées 1947 les grandes grèves
et les manifestations
mai 68 la france paralysée jusqu'aux
accords de grenelle
tout cela paraît bien loin par quelques
points chauds les français font surtout
la grève de la grève
l'an dernier malgré les journées
d'action de la cgt seulement 880000
journées perdues pour un arrêt de
travail
trois ou quatre fois moins que dans les
années 70 du jamais vu depuis la
libération situation apparemment
paradoxale en période de crise et de
difficultés
apparemment seulement car pour beaucoup
le premier frein
rêve c'est le chômage la crainte du
chômage les gens qui ont du travail
disent nous avons au moins ça pour le
reste on verra plus tard
mais il ne faut pas s'y tromper
le mécontentement est réel
autre explication avancée la perte
d'influencé des syndicats la gauche au
pouvoir et une meilleure concertation
dans les entreprises
un lien certain nombre de lois nouvelles
ont été votées et donc on a introduit
dans les entreprises la société
française l'obligation de négocier le
droit d'expression donc les directions
son billet de niveau 6 au moins une fois
par an donc toutes les grèves l'avait
les banderoles on veut négocier toutes
ces grèves là le seul lors elles ont
disparu
il y avait aussi des grèves de
ras-le-bol d'ateliers à l'égard des
chefs des carreaux cassés et donc quand
les groupes d'expression arrivée
exprimer leurs besoins à obtenir les
changements ces raisons-là de grève de
ras-le-bol d'ateliers pour partie au
diminué alors la fin des grèves prudents
même si l'histoire ne se répète jamais
rappelons que la dernière période de
grand calme social c'était dans les
premiers mois 2009 168 juste avant mais
la bourse de paris se porte toujours
aussi bien ce vendredi c'était le
premier jour du mois boursier et la
hausse des valeurs étaient sans
précédent +3 4%
la régie renault vient de rendre public
les objectifs qu'elle s'est fixés pour
son nouveau modèle r21 cette voiture
sera commercialisée à partir du 6 mars
prochain et alain nourrice qui a voulu
tester cet air 21 avec un automobiliste
le constructeur et puis un concurrent il
y a plusieurs façons de regarder la r21
d'abord avec les yeux attentifs du
consommateur il examinera en premier
lieu la ligne de cette berline moyenne
l'avant rappelle celui de la r25
l'arrière quoi c'est d'un coffre au et
volumineux si la silhouette et la taille
qu'on vienne le consommateur voudra
alors connaître le prix de 67 mille
francs pour la version t elle à 100 de
1400 francs
la turbo dx dans cette gamme de prix
l'acheteur aura ensuite le choix entre
trois motorisations 1 litre cette de
l'it ou 2 litres/100 à noter que sur
tous les modèles
la gestion électronique du moteur est
prêt les yeux du constructeur maintenant
ceux de la régie scrute l'avenir il vise
un redressement financier d'ici deux ans
renault compte sur la r21 pour se
repositionner dans le créneau important
des voitures moyennes supérieures ses
ventes en france pour ce type de
véhicules ont chuté passant de 37 à 14 %
entre 81 et 85 de façon globale la régie
est passé pendant la même période du
premier au sixième rang des
constructeurs européens la r21 possède
des atouts importants pour remonter
cette pente
outre son aérodynamisme favorisant une
économie de carburant
des aménagements intérieurs tels que la
banquette arrière rabattable peuvent
influencer la décision des acheteurs les
autres constructeurs eux observent du
coin de l'oeil cette nouvelle venue les
concurrents sont non peugeot 305 citroën
bx et puis à l'étranger audi 90 fiat
croma ford sierra opel ascona et
volkswagen passat
si la r21 remporte le succès espéré par
son constructeur
la production pourrait atteindre 1800
véhicules par jour plus de 1000
véhicules sortirait de l'usine-pilote de
sandouville
le reste serait produit à douai maubeuge
à rennes en belgique où palencia en
espagne les ravisseurs de monsieur
françois lambert directeur d'une
entreprise de peinture enlevé mardi soir
à sève dans le département des
hauts-de-seine se sont manifestés
aujourd'hui un coup de téléphone la
famille de monsieur norbert pour lui
demander si la rançon était bien réunis
dans le livre des records nous avions
comme doyen de l'humanité un japonais
monsieur shige fille aux eats-unis il
vivait sur une petite île au sud du
japon
le voici est un peu édenté est vrai
qu'il était né le 29 juin 1865
sa famille a annoncé aujourd'hui qu'il
était mort paisiblement ce matin sans
avoir pu fêter donc son 121e
anniversaire il n'avait qu'une seule
réponse à propos de sa longévité
réveil à 5h et à chaque dîner une petite
fiole de chouchou vous savez un alcool
doux de canne à sucre
les césar du cinéma français seront
décernés demain et ce sera en direct sur
antenne 2 cérémonie présentée par michel
drucker il y a comme à l'habitude
beaucoup de nominer il y aura donc
beaucoup moins d'élus tout simplement ce
soir ce soir voici les césars de france
roche vingt films en course
subway de luc besson est proposé pour
douze prix l'effrontée de claude miller
pour 8 ainsi que mon honneur que je foi
de jacques deray
peut-on mettre la foule sceptre position
de tribun pour péril en la demeure de
michel deville et autant pour que le
rendez vous d'andré téchiné fille
nomination pour trois hommes et un
couffin de coline serreau et 6 4% toit
ni loi d'agnès varda
alors je me risque voici mes coups de
coeur qui ne va peut-être pas du tout à
l'unisson des deux mille votants mon
meilleur film en c l'effrontée parce
qu'il est si tendre
mon meilleur réalisateur michel deville
parce que son habileté est aussi
diabolique que son film
meilleur acteur de l'année michel
serrault parce qu'il est au sommet de la
discrétion dans le brio
meilleures actrices sandrine bonnaire
parce qu'elle possède l'intuition qui
fait mouche les yeux fermés meilleur
second rôle jean hugues anglade pour son
flegme et son humour et bernadette
lafont pour sa chaleur meilleur espoir
lucas belvaux pour sa fraîcheur
roublarde et charlotte gainsbourg pour
sa fragilité
enfin à raismes meilleur premier film
parce qu alex joffé possède à 30 ans la
virtuosité d'un vieux routier ont fait
un meilleur film étranger ran parce que
quiros awa est un des cinq absolument
grands du cinéma mondial
même un lambert wilson et son presque
homonyme christophe lambert sont bien
séduisant jean-pierre michel nicole
garcia brûle d'un feu glacé qui ne
touche jean pierre bacri et michel
boujenah font rire toujours avec eux et
jamais contre eux
et charlotte valandrey aller 17
enjolivant ravageur enfin cocorico
féminine c'est la première fois qu'on
trouve quatre réalisatrices en piste au
départ
coline serreau agnès varda virginie
ternay et susan seidelman ça serait
tellement bien qu un flat du 4 à
l'arrivée il y aura un tiercé demain sur
l'hippodrome d'enghien dans le prix de
valenciennes 18 partants et pronostics
depuis adresse qui vous recommande de
jouer le 17 auquel diot le naphta lunga
le deux paires huguen le 5 horde
précisent-ils e18 odile mabon le 16
hoblyn de l'aria le 8 homme bon wauquiez
et le cas polka barbès et puis pour la
météorologie simonetta soyez gentils
fait une bonne météo n'oubliez pas nous
sommes sur la deux qu'on se le dise les
vocal sarah froid très froid même alors
on espérait une confrontation
un peu de soleil par exemple mais se
fera car dossier voici pourquoi nous
allons voir avec la photo satellite
parce que cette masse nuageuse très
important qui obscurcit le ciel du sud
et surtout du sud ouest aujourd'hui va
glisser progressivement de plus en plus
vers le sud-est et enfin parce qu'une
autre perturbation va descendre des îles
britanniques à leurs résultats sur la
carte de demain en tout cas sur toute la
moitié nord
des nuages des nuages surtout cette
moitié nord donnant des averses de neige
régulièrement nuages aussi sur tout le
sud avec un ciel qui s'éclaircira quand
même sur le sud-ouest de l'après midi
mais toujours des précipitations sur le
sud-est et la corse
et puis entre ces deux zones du beau
temps côté températures c'est la baisse
très très net diminuera dans l'après
midi qu'une seule température positive à
brest 2 degrés partout ailleurs de moins
8 à 0 degrés sur la moitié nord et de -4
à 12 degrés sur la moitié sud
alors demain ce sera le samedi 2 2 22
février le soleil se lèvera et c'est ce
que nous allons voir à 7h48 se couchera
à 18h21 ce sera la sainte isabelle ce
sera aussi une journée où les vacanciers
de la zone 2 et ceux de la zone iii se
retrouveront alors bison futé vous
conseille de ne pas partir entre 8 et 16
heures
et il faut savoir aussi que la
circulation sera très chargée entre 16h
et 18h
en fait il vaudrait mieux partir
dimanche
dans l'actualité de cette journée je
vous rappelle le naufrage d'un chalutier
français au large de l'ecosse 18
pêcheurs originaires de fécamp sont
morts pour deux d'entre eux et seize
sont portés disparus
et puis deuxième titre de l'actualité de
ce 21 février deux palestiniens qui est
été condamné pour le meurtre d'un
représentant de l'olp et ont été libérés
sous conditions et expulsés de france
après sept années de prison
le dernier journal vous sera présentée
par philippe harrouard à 22h50 juste
après apostrophe je vous dis à demain
20h bonsoir merci